-There's just
a little over one day left
in the presidency
of Donald Trump.
And as we survey the damage
he'll leave behind
and the impeachment trial
he faces ahead,
we're learning more about
the insurrection he incited,
his premeditated plan
to steal the election,
and the complicity of virtually
the entire Republican Party.
Oh, and also Trump met
with the My Pillow guy.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
On Friday, as an incoming
Democratic administration
was preparing
for the second time in 12 years
to take the reins
from a deeply unpopular
outgoing Republican president
who left the nation in ruins,
we got a revealing split screen
of what our politics
are like right now
with the Trump White House
being boxed up
and the Biden administration
preparing to take over.
We were presented with
a very stark choice
for where we want to go
as a country.
On the one hand,
President-Elect Biden
unveiled a five-point plan
to overhaul
the botched vaccine rollout
and stem the tide of
the deadly coronavirus pandemic
that's been willfully neglected
by the Trump White House.
-President-Elect Joe Biden
is pushing ahead
with plans to activate
the Defense Production Act
and ramp up
the national supply
of the coronavirus vaccine.
-The incoming administration
pledging to get
100 million doses
in the first 100 days
after Joe Biden takes office.
The plan including
mass vaccination centers
and training
an Army of vaccinators,
among other steps.
-And to staff up these centers,
we will mobilize
thousands of clinical and
nonclinical professionals.
This will be one of the most
challenging operational efforts
ever undertaken by our country.
But you have my word:
we will manage the hell
out of this operation.
-Whenever he's
giving a pep talk,
Biden's got the vibe
of a retired
high school football coach
taking his grandkids
to Chuck E. Cheese.
"Alright, let's draw it up
on the chalkboard.
Taylor, you're gonna run
the slant route to Super Slide.
Katie, you're gonna post up
at the arcade.
And, Tim, you're gonna go deep
in the ball pit,
but remember you must come back
in 30 minutes
so we can manage the hell
out of some pizza!"
But I got to say, the whole
"President a plan" thing
is a genuine relief after
four years of Dr. Head Injury
over here swinging wildly
between "Everything is fine" and
"We're all gonna die."
"This coronavirus, it's just
gonna go away, folks.
It's gonna go away.
And as soon as it does,
the Antifa caravans
are gonna arrive,
and it's not gonna be pretty.
You'll be praying
for coronavirus
when the caravans show up."
So, that's what the incoming
President was doing on Friday.
What about
the outgoing president?
Who was he meeting with?
Can I assume it was also
an expert of some kind?
Perhaps a doctor, a scientist,
or maybe it was someone
who specializes in
public health infrastructure
and mass vaccination planning?
Ooh, wouldn't that be great?
You know what?
Let me just set up the old
chin cradle and find out.
-One of the president's
visitors today, Mike Lindell,
the founder of My Pillow,
was seen over here
at the White House,
outside the West Wing.
The White House official
did tell me, Wolf,
that it is believed that
the president and Lindell met.
-A "Washington Post"
photographer got a close-up
of the notes that he
was carrying with him.
And, Jake, when you
zoom in on them,
you can see that he is talking
about the election.
Things like martial law
are mentioned.
The words "taken immediately
to save the Constitution."
-The guy from My Pillow
is carrying documents
and talking
to President Trump --
presumably about
declaring martial law.
-You know what?
I think this chin cradle
is bad luck.
I'm gonna stop using it.
But that's just great.
The My Pillow guy,
AKA The Notorious MPG,
who, it should be noted,
is not even good at pillows,
is walking into the White House
with an insane suggestion
for the president.
What's next? The ShamWow Guy
strolling in
with a notepad that says
"Become an X-Man?"
Also, not to be judgmental,
but if I was going to a meeting
to tell the president
he should declare martial law,
I might not
need to write it down.
Was there a risk you were gonna
forget that part?
"Good meeting, Mike.
Anything else?"
"Uh, let's see, I told you
Hugo Chávez
hacked the elections.
Filled you in on our new
three-ply mattress topper.
You know, I'm sorry,
Mr. President.
Let me, uh, check my notes.
Oh, duh-dur!
I forgot you should
declare martial law.
This is why
I write things down!"
Also, just
a random thought here,
but this is one of those moments
where I'm reminded
that there were voters --
not many, but some --
who were torn
between Trump and Biden.
Hmm, the guy with
a five-point plan
to build the infrastructure
for mass vaccination
during a deadly pandemic,
or a guy whose best friend
is obviously
a psychotic pillow salesman.
It's a coin flip!"
Although I think my favorite
detail from the Lindell meeting
involves White House counsel
Pat Cipollone,
who met with Lindell after a
series of White House officials
basically kept trying to pass
Lindell off to someone else.
First, Trump met with Lindell,
but it was a brief meeting.
Trump sent him upstairs to the
White House counsel's office.
Lindell was then escorted
by the national security
adviser, Robert O'Brien.
O'Brien, seeking
to end the conversation,
said if there was evidence
of what he was saying,
it should go
to White House counsel,
and he steered Lindell upstairs
to the counsel's office.
Then, once Lindell
got to the counsel's office,
Lindell spoke sharply
to one of Cipollone's assistants
after he was brought upstairs.
Cipollone told him
he wouldn't speak to him
until Lindell apologized to her.
So everyone just kept trying
to get rid of him
by passing him off
to someone else.
In fact, Lindell is still in
the White House, as we speak,
getting shunted
from office to office.
The White House chef
just got done telling him
what kind of flour they use,
and now he's pitching his plan
to the lawnmower kid.
"Do you know how to declare
martial law?!"
You know, you could also just
not let him into the building.
Why is it easier
to get into the White House
than a restaurant in Chelsea
during brunch?
Also I'm glad Cipollone stood up
for his assistant.
But that's
the line you're drawing?
"I'm sorry, but I simply
will not allow you
to spread your deranged theories
about Hugo Chávez
coming back from the dead
to hack the election
unless you learn some manners!"
"I'm sorry.
Will you declare martial law...
please?"
This whole situation
is so perfectly indicative
of the entire Trump era.
Instead of just saying,
"No! Get out!"
they all go to absurd lengths
to debase themselves
to accommodate Trump and
his circle of crazy old men
with mysteriously brown hair.
That's why he had to invent
his own pillow.
All the other ones
look like a saddle
after three nights.
And indulging Trump,
as we've learned,
has real-world consequences.
Thanks to Trump and his allies
in the GOP and right-wing media
repeating their deranged lies
about the election,
a new CNN poll found
that 75% of Republicans
believe Biden isn't
the legitimate president.
Virtually the entirety
of the Republican Party,
with only a few exceptions,
like the 10 Republicans
who voted for the impeachment,
has taken a hard turn
against democracy
and towards authoritarianism.
And instead of standing up
and saying clearly
that we need to tell the truth
about the election
and ostracize anyone
who doesn't accept it,
senior Republicans are insisting
that we all need to capitulate
to Trump in order
to appease his lunatic base.
Lindsey Graham, for example,
pleaded with his party
not to hold Trump accountable
for inciting
the violent insurrection
at the Capitol.
-Mr. President, your policies
will stand the test of time.
You're the most important figure
in the Republican Party.
You can shape
the direction of the party,
keep your movement alive.
If we embrace an
unconstitutional impeachment
of Donald Trump
after he's out of office,
it will destroy the party.
The Republican Party
wants to move forward.
President Trump's going to be
the most important voice
in the Republican Party
for a long time to come.
He's going to accept
responsibility
for his part on
January the 6th,
but impeaching him
after he leaves office
is not only unconstitutional,
from a Republican point of view,
it would destroy our party.
-You know what?
If holding Trump accountable
for inciting
violent insurrection
destroys the Republican Party,
then so be it.
You want to build it back up
again into something decent,
be my guest.
But now Lindsey Graham
is like an admiral
in the Galactic Empire,
saying, "Guys, don't leave
the exhaust port open,
or it will destroy
the Death Star."
Also, what do you mean
Donald Trump's going to accept
responsibility for
his part on January 6th?
Are you nuts?
Just because you sound like
a character
in a Tennessee Williams play
doesn't mean you have to
act like one, too.
"Oh, what's Lindsey
doin' on the front porch?"
"Oh, he's still out there
waiting for Donald Trump
to accept responsibility
for January 6th.
Oh, Lindsey!
When will you ever learn?"
"He's comin', Mama.
He knows he was wrong,
and he's comin'.
Isn't that right,
Glass Unicorn?"
[ Laughter ]
At this point, it's difficult
to ignore the reality
that the Republican Party is,
from the top down,
a threat to our democracy.
Trump is leaving the nation
in ruins,
with the lowest approval rating
of any President
in modern history;
400,000 Americans have died
in the coronavirus pandemic;
there are 3 million fewer jobs
than when Trump took office;
the vaccine rollout
is a disaster;
a violent insurrection
fueled by a deranged
authoritarian movement
killed multiple people,
ransacked the Capitol,
and nearly toppled
American democracy;
there are 20,000 troops
guarding D.C.;
and instead of banishing Trump
from politics to jail
or to his golf course, where
he'd be glimpsed only rarely,
through blurry photos, like
some sort of fairway Bigfoot,
Lindsey Graham wants him
to remain a leader
in the Republican Party
for years to come.
You know what that makes you,
Lindsey? A coconspirator.
It's like if a guy
on your bowling team
turned out to be a cannibal,
and you said,
"Don't turn him in.
The championship's next week.
So what if he ate Carl?
Carl was dead weight anyway."
Seriously, is there anyone
slimier than Lindsey Graham?
He called Trump a crazy bigot
who was unfit for office;
warned accurately that if
the GOP nominated Trump,
they'd get destroyed
and deserve it;
then did an about-face
and became
Trump's loyal foot soldier,
golf buddy, and Mini-Me;
then, after the insurrection,
said, "Count me out.
Enough is enough";
then flew with Trump
on Air Force One;
and now he's saying
we shouldn't impeach him.
He's like a hostage negotiator
who says,
"You want a helicopter
and $1 million?
I'll give you something
better -- me."
These people had four years
rationalizing and excusing
Trump's behavior because
they were all in on it.
Long ago, they decided to
disgrace themselves
and service this monstrous
and irredeemable man,
and this dismantling
of our democracy
is just the culmination
of all that.
And even the ones
who didn't technically object
to the electoral votes
the way Josh Hawley or Ted Cruz
did are complicit.
It's a moral rot that runs
through virtually the entirety
of the Republican Party
and conservative movement.
You might remember
that when it first became clear
Trump had lost the election,
more than a few Republicans said
there was no harm
in indulging him.
Remember, we knew in advance
it would take days
to count the votes,
and it was clear
soon after the election
that Joe Biden hadn't just won,
he won handily,
with 7 million more votes
across the country
and a total of
306 electoral votes,
including states Republicans
had held for decades,
like Georgia and Arizona.
And yet Republicans insisted
on going to absurd lengths
to pretend that the result
was still up in the air.
They were like Browns fans
holding out hope for a comeback
on Monday morning.
"You're telling me
a 35-year-old backup quarterback
runs for 13 yards
with a minute left
to ice the game?
I call fraud."
And I'm sorry, Browns fans.
I was nice last week,
but you beat my Steelers,
and now you get
a Gentle Payback Burn.
Even aside from propagating
the malicious lie
that the election was stolen,
they kept repeating
the ridiculous talking point
that Trump had every right
to pursue his legal objections,
which is a little bit
like Browns fans saying they
have a right to protest
the results of the game
after the Super Bowl.
Okay, okay, the second burn
was unnecessary,
and I apologize
because that's piling on,
kind of like
how the Chiefs defense
piled on your quarterback
last night.
Okay, no, I'm sorry!
I'm sad about the Steelers!
It's not about you!
It's about me! My problem!
I can't let go!
[ Laughter ]
I don't like being like this!
Anyway, the point is,
Republicans did
what they've been doing
for five years now --
indulging Trump,
hoping they'll be able
to appease him and his voters
while getting
everything they want
with no damage to the system --
a strategy that's worked out
great so far.
In fact, they went
to absurd lengths
to humiliate themselves
in service of a man
they knew to be craven and
sadistic and deranged.
You might remember one of the
most infamous examples
from North Dakota
Senator Kevin Cramer,
who was asked if he considered
Joe Biden the president-elect
after the Electoral College
certified Joe Biden's win.
And this was
Cramer's full answer.
at this point, so we'll see
how the e-mails turn out."
Oh, my God, that was like
if Gary Busey
body-swapped into an 8th grader
who was just about to do
his oral report
on the Electoral College.
"Ugh! What now?!"
These guys are
such spineless weasels
that if you ask them
one simple question
about who won the election,
they turn into
malfunctioning droids.
He sounds like an Echo that
just got dropped in the toilet.
"Alexa, is Joe Biden
the president-elect?"
-Well, it seems to me
that being elected
by the Electoral College
is a threshold
where a title like that is
probably most appropriate --
-Okay, never mind, never mind.
Just play Taylor Swift.
-Playing "PopoZao"
by Kevin Federline.
-No, no, no, play Taylor Swift.
-Playing "PopoZao"
by Kevin Federline.
-I said, "Play Taylor Swift."
-Playing Taylor Swift.
-Thank you.
-Covering "PopoZao"
by Kevin Federline.
-Alexa!
[ Laughter ]
Now Cramer and Graham
are the kinds of guys
who don't get as much attention
as, say, Hawley and Cruz,
because they just went along
for the ride
while Hawley and Cruz
led the way.
For example, new footage
from "The New Yorker" reveals
that once the insurrectionists
got inside the Senate chamber,
they made clear they
considered Cruz an ally.
-Look here, look.
-Ted Cruz's objections
to Arizona.
-His objection.
He was gonna sell us out
all along.
-Really? [Bleep]
-Objection to counting
electoral votes
on the state of Arizona.
-Can I get a photo of that?
[ Indistinct conversation ]
-[Bleep].
-Cool shout-out, Ted.
Congrats.
That's like
the seditionist version
of getting a song dedicated
to you by the morning zoo crew.
"This insurrection goes out
to Ted from Calgary.
Thanks for helping us
overthrow a democracy, Ted!"
[ Air horn blowing ]
[ Laughter ]
"This Taylor Swift cover
of "PopoZao"
is going out to Ted Cruz."
[ Laughter ]
Trump telegraphed for months
that he was going to do
exactly what he did --
try to steal the election
and refuse to accept
the outcome.
And over the weekend,
we learned from new reporting
what we basically already knew
from Trump's own words
and actions --
that the attempt
to steal the election
was premeditated and planned
long in advance.
According to Axios...
Oh, really, you were stunned?
That's like watching
that Werner Herzog documentary
about the dude who
hangs out with grizzly bears
and being stunned when he
gets eaten by a grizzly bear.
You think Werner's gonna
make a documentary
where the dude and the bear
end up as buddies?
"And as I watched man and bear
frolic in the stream,
their friendship unbreakable,
I realized something
to be clear.
This movie was a dud."
[ Laughter ]
It's like, I love
when they bring back
characters from season one
for the finale.
Now they're gonna have to call
Reince Priebus
as a witness
in the impeachment trial.
It's gonna be like
the "Seinfeld" finale.
Oh, you know who else
is gonna be a witness?
Trump's lawyer.
-New this morning, Rudy Giuliani
now says
that he will not represent
President Trump
during his impeachment trial.
The president's
personal attorney says
that he can not be part of
the president's legal team,
because he also gave a speech
to supporters
moments before the siege
on the Capitol.
During his speech,
he told crowds
to engage in "trial by combat."
Giuliani says this makes him
a witness to the day's events.
-Trump is such a criminal,
his lawyers are also criminals.
"Your honor, my client
isn't the murderer; I am.
Just ask my client -- he was
there, because he helped me.
It's gonna be impossible
for Trump to find
a lawyer who
isn't also an accomplice.
I mean, no credible lawyer wants
to get anywhere near this guy.
Just look what happened to Rudy.
He was already
under criminal investigation.
Now he could get charged
for inciting a riot.
He might get kicked out of the
New York State Bar Association,
and he hasn't been watered
in months.
Every soulless Republican today
who accommodated
this obviously deranged
president for four years,
every spineless factotum
who carried out the business
of keeping the institutional
Republican Party
aligned with Trump
shares in the destruction
they've wrought
and the shame
that comes with it.
And we all have to reckon
with the fact
that this isn't going away.
Trump's not unique.
He's not alone.
He's the emblem and embodiment
of the modern Republican Party.
If they want to fix that,
the bare minimum they can do
is cast him out
and disqualify him from
ever holding office again.
But even then
the rot Trump exposed
will remain throughout the GOP,
from Fox News
to Lindsey Graham
to Rudy Giuliani to...
-The guy from My Pillow.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV, AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses.
They need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can click the Donate button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
wear a mask.
We love you.